which is really the the mechanism at the
at the core of all economies it's the
money creation mechanism
where does money come from
um and it's funny because when you study
economics as i've done
um i mean in any discipline whether it's
chemistry or physics or whatever you
know
you study it at the top universities you
expect
to become an expert in the important
stuff in your discipline
but when you study economics they don't
really teach you about
the money creation process and the
monetary mechanism
because the leading economic theories
and models as you know i mean they
i mean the the highbrow ones they they
don't even have any money whatsoever in
their model
um it's an abstracted um theoretical
economy where essentially people
exchange
things by a barter that's what they
assume
because money doesn't matter so we might
as well take it out of the equation it
just confuses things
i mean there's the famous book by david
romer
in fact i did a survey what's in in the
uk at british universities
what is the most widely used
masters level macroeconomics textbook
and it was david romer
you know it's his key book on
macroeconomics and growth
and and on page three it says um
you know essentially for more than half
in the in the book we
the models and theories don't include
money because this would only confuse
matters
we heard from jay powell just a few days
ago that it was no longer an appropriate
part it was no no longer an appropriate
mechanism for central banks to look at
the money supply and that is that is the
orthodoxy
yeah yeah yes indeed indeed but
but really it's it's surprising that he
says this now at this late stage because
certainly since
2008 a lot of people have realized that
oh
you know we neglected the monetary
mechanism
and and really um we can't just
exclude money uh we have to understand
how it works and where money comes from
and that was also my original puzzle
when i was shimomura fellow in tokyo in
1991 and i had this
this task to my research topic
uh on the basis of which i became the
first shimomura fellow was
to figure out japanese capital flows
that were buying up the world as you
started out mentioning you know japanese
money buying
pebbles golf course um rockefeller
center
columbia pictures whatever in australia
in hawaii and
in the uk they were buying up companies
real estate whatever
you name it um and it was just so much
money that
no standard economic model could explain
it all
the world's experts were saying we don't
know there is no answer
somebody told me oh there's this you
know famous u.s economist jeffrey
sachs he was recently in tokyo at
meaty the ministry of industry and trade
with his
i think former phd's and peter boone and
they've they've written a paper on just
this topic
richard you should go and speak to meaty
they will have the paper
and i went there met various bureaucrats
and they told me yes yeah
uh professor sax and peter boone they
were here oh yes we have their
discussion paper
which they presented and it was because
my fundamental idea was it it's clearly
linked to these
crazy asset prices land prices where the
imperial palace garden had as you said
the same value as the entire state of
california including los angeles san
francisco you name it
crazy um and so that there had to be a
link but what precisely was the link
there was the paper jeffrey sacks peter
boone
i was delighted because you know i was
just i barely finished my my first
degree at the lse
by the end of it i was very disappointed
to find there is no link that was their
conclusion
there is no link why the argument was
well okay you've got totally overpriced
japanese real estate
to the extent that it makes sense for
japanese land owners to just sell a
tiny plot of land and buy you know buy a
few big chunks of california why not
you know just for diversification
purpose alone would make sense and that
would give you the mechanism
but they were arguing well hang on even
if you did that which seems perfectly
rational
this wouldn't affect um capital outflows
or the
or the whole you know monetary situation
why because
who you know if you own the land and you
want to cash in you've got to sell it
and who's buying it and foreigners were
not buying japanese land because it was
outlandishly expensive so it was only
other japanese who were buying the land
and therefore it's just money moving
from japanese owner
a to japanese land owner b and therefore
plus minus zero international impact
there shouldn't be any international
impact
which was a logical argument but richard
kuh at the time he was known as
a capital flow expert and i told him
about my my job my task i need to find
out
what is this link between
the property market and capital flows or
otherwise what
explains these capital flows and and he
told me look richard
forget it you won't be able to solve
this one it's too complicated
no nobody has a model that works
so but it didn't give up that was a
challenge
it certainly was a challenge i mean all
the experts were saying
it you know there is no link doesn't you
know do something else
you won't be able to crack to crack that
nut
so but the conclusion is that i did find
out
it's a very simple insight which at the
same time answered so many other
questions as well
it goes straight to this money creation
process
the answer is that know that the land
owners
that want to cash in and diversify and
invest abroad they don't need to sell
their land
they just use it as collateral to borrow
money from a bank
but now comes the next step what happens
when you borrow money from a bank
what happens then all the finance
leading finance journals
and most textbooks will tell you well
banks are financial intermediaries they
gather deposits
they do the analysis on credit you know
evaluation and credit rating and all
sorts and then they
use some of those deposits and lend it
out so their financial intermediaries
are just in between the depositors
and the final use of the money
but it's not true but the conclusion is
this is not actually what happens
when a bank gives out a loan banks are
not financial intermediaries
um i could show this with data
but empirically i i approve this only
much later
this is published only in 2014
where did a separate empirical test this
is using
um german banking data because really
see
this financial intermediation theory is
only one of three theories of banking
and it's extraordinary i mean banking
has been around for five thousand years
you go back to
ancient babylonia and there were
essentially modern banks there was a
credit economy
um there was interest being charged
there were
collateralized loans uncollateralized
loans cashless transactions
you know it was a proper banking system
because essentially
banking is accounting and they kept good
records and we have them in the british
museum thousands and thousands of clay
tablets right
in cuneiform where they they note and
they're mostly accounting records and
banking records
so banking is ancient yet until
recently there's been a debate
still an ongoing debate a controversial
debate about
how banks actually work and there's
these three theories of banking now
the one that i described is the dominant
one the conventional one that's
in all the textbooks and finance journal
journal of finance and and so on
journal of uh money credit and banking
they think
banks are financial intermediaries this
is not based on
on empirical evidence by the way now
there's a second theory and that's the
older one
and um some people remember because that
used to be taught
in the textbooks also in economics
namely the fractional reserve theory of
banking
which says that well a bank always has
to
put a percentage um of the
of their deposits with the central bank
the fractional reserve and say it's
let's say
if it's one percent the bank gets a new
deposit of a hundred dollars
it will put one dollar with the central
bank and lend out 99 but the 99 will
then become somebody else's
some other banks new deposit when you
use it
and that bank will then put one percent
aside give it to the central bank as a
reserve and lend out
99 of that 98 point you know
and so on so the whole thing continues
that will then become
uh some other banks deposit each time
the amount gets smaller
and it's a geometric progression and
mathematically and you can calculate the
total
and with a one percent reserve
requirement the
100 initial deposit become 10
000 in aggregate in total deposits
the central bank has 100
as their total reserves from all the
banks these small amounts
and total new lending in the banking
system is 9
900. that's the fractional reserve
theory it's sort of
slightly complicated but sort of also i
mean there's a certain logic to it
um now that's not any more popular
as as you may know you may have noticed
i mean nowadays they
they don't talk about this they talk
only about this financial intermediate
theory banks are like non-banks there's
no
no difference now there's a third theory
and that one is the oldest that one was
popular from
essentially well until roughly the 1920s
1930s that's when the
fraction reserve theory started to
become dominant until the 60s
then we had the financial intermediation
theory and this oldest theory
is the credit creation theory of banking
now that's the
the most surprising one and that one
says
banks are not financial intermediaries
they do not intermediate they actually
creators of money
and when a bank gives out a loan
this is newly created money that's added
to the money supply but not
like in the fraction reserve story in
some kind of indirect collective
fashion where you can't kind of grasp
where's the money creation oh it's just
in the system it happens in sequence
no the credit creation theory says now
each individual bank
creates new money when when it gives out
a new loan
so these three theories they differ in
in terms of
the question of when a bank lends money
where does the money come from